we use our hands to interact with
objects grab them manipulate them and
release them in virtual reality however
such fine-grain interaction with virtual
objects is generally not possible
the main constraint to successfully
render haptics for virtual objects in a
realistic way is that the controller
must be able to produce and endure human
scale forces during interaction and
persist in rendering feedback especially
when grasping and squeezing objects when
the forces on the controller are the
highest we present the capstan crunch
the haptic controller that uses
controlled brake technology to render
haptic grasp at varying compliance
levels and that can sustain human scale
grasping forces up to 20 Newtons it does
so by using capstan based brake for
variable pure resistive forces and a
clutch cable spring that is capable of
outfitting the stored energy of a
built-in spring this duality capstan
break + clutched spring creates a unique
device that can go beyond limitation of
the binary break or a spring and can
simulate human scale forces
in a simulation of a push button the
user finger reaches the surface of the
material represented by a brake and
pushes it in against a resistance of a
sprint up until some point where the
brake is being released and the user
feels the operation of the click of the
button until the button reaches full
brake
another example of interaction
implemented with Captain Crunch is an
assembly of toy construction Brooke
there are three stages to the assembly
first the two blocks are brought
together by bringing the fingers closer
in stage two a force is applied to
connect the two blocks together once the
blocks are connected the brakes comes
into full stop and then the finger
retreats
final example of interaction implemented
with Captain Crunch allows user to cut
materials with the pair of scissors
the gradual growth of the force due to
increase of the material lever length is
approximated by a set of discrete steps
we presented capstan crunch a haptic
controller for rendering grasping
feedback up to human scale forces
capstan crunch is build around novel
linear adjustable friction based capstan
break that renders human scale forces
without the use of large high force
electrically powered consumptive and
expensive actuators